[Applaudissements]
casser les codes ça vous dit quelque
chose
c'est un peu la nouvelle formule à la
mode le Carpe Diem des temps modernes
car tout comme pour la célèbre locution
latine on a un peu du mal à définir
casser les codes d'accord mais lesquels
et pourquoi
et avec quoi
parce qu'on remarquera nos difficultés
que le choix du verbe n'est pas anodin
on ne dit pas changer les codes encore
moins réécrire les codes il y a ici une
volonté d'action de mouvement brusque et
réel
si je dis à quelqu'un qui me casse les
pieds
c'est avant tout pour le signifier que
si il continue à me tourner autour ce
sont les siens que je vais écraser
alors quand on dit que l'on veut casser
les codes qu'est-ce que l'on sous-entend
vraiment
et bien
à vrai dire cette envie ne date pas
d'hier
on peut même trouver des exemples dans
les prémices de l'histoire tenez
Adam et
d'une seule et unique règle pas touche à
la pomme
et il y en avait des fruits différents
dans le jardin des têtes
pourtant on sait tous lequel leur a valu
leur exclusion définitive du Paradis
la traite pour l'interdit effacer toutes
les mises en garde leur avait été
énoncée tout ça pour une pomme
et bien ce n'est pas si simple un seul
code de conduite un seul code de pensée
cela a été finalement trop contraignant
pour les humains quelle ironie
en poursuivant notre traversée des
époques on remarquera que ce fruit
défendu réapparaît brusquement dans le
quotidien d'un homme pour changer à
jamais sa vision du monde
vous l'aurez compris bien sûr il s'agit
de ce cher Isaac Newton éminent
scientifique du XVIIe siècle qui en
observant la chute perpendiculaire de
cet objet on est parvenu à la conclusion
qu'il existait une force capable de nous
retenir à la surface de la Terre la
gravité
un concept qui parlera sûrement
davantage aux amateurs des sorial
colisés mais surtout une manière
nouvelle d'aborder les codes de la
physique
en détruisant ce qui existait jusque là
avec ces deux exemples déjà on peut
observer une réalité
casser les codes ce n'est pas sans
conséquence
alors oui bien sûr tout dépendra de
l'échelle à laquelle auront lieu les
événements et même la plus infime
rupture aura un impact même vous à qui
s'adressent ces mots avait déjà très
certainement eu au cours de votre ville
occasion de penser imaginez proposer des
actes qui seraient contraires aux règles
que l'on vous aurait dicté à la
naissance
n'avez-vous jamais entendu par exemple
qu'il y a d'usage pour les jeunes
garçons de jouer aux voitures et pour
les fillettes d'aimer les princesses
cette simple phrase vous fait grimacer
ou sourire c'est qu'un consciemment déjà
vous avez tenté de vous y opposer avec
ou sans succès
mais la réflexion de s'arrête pas là
vous voyez vous
si je m'étais trouvé devant vous ne vend
plus tôt de la même manière
qu'aujourd'hui un détail ne vous aurez
pas échappé
en effet avant le 31 janvier 2013 le
port du pantalon pour les femmes était
légalement interdit autorisé simplement
si elles seront des au commissariat de
police pendant demander l'autorisation
bon évidemment c'est très n'était plus
respecté depuis les années 60 mais
pourtant bien inscrite dans le Code
civil français
et si je recule encore de santé en
arrière en 1920 je n'aurais peut-être
même pas eu la chance d'entrer dans une
école d'ingénieur puisque les femmes
obtenaient tout juste le droit de passer
leur baccalauréat et d'accéder aux
études secondaires
ainsi ceux qui aujourd'hui vous apparaît
comme une normalité était il y a encore
quelques années une révolution
ces femmes du XXème siècle qui ont brisé
les codes de leur époque ont permis dans
un sommet de nouveau
respecter de tous et qui permettent une
certaine égalité entre les genres
Voltaire disait ils ont été faites à
mesure selon les temps les lieux les
besoins
lorsque les besoins ont changé les lois
qui sont demeurées sont devenues
ridicules
c'est une manière un peu plus jolie de
dire que les codes ont tes ont évolué
avec les façons de penser et qu'il faut
savoir les remettre en question
finalement il faut accepter la fin de
quelque chose pour en construire une
nouvelle cette phrase là je l'ai piqué
adamso comme quoi que l'on soit rappeur
ou philosophe
de se poser la question
casser les codes à force est-ce que ce
ne serait pas les conserver
quant à ces temps vous énoncez avec
révolte à vos parents que vous refusez
de faire la sieste parce que vous êtes
trop grand
ce n'est pas pour un sourire le code de
non siècle c'est plutôt pour leur
témoigner votre sentiment d'injustice et
les faire réagir
derrière ce tout petit tact se cache une
vérité majeure
casser les codes c'est avant tout un
processus
vous imaginez si Newton était arrivé
devant ses pairs avec sa pomme et sa
révélation il lui aurait sûrement
proposé de casser la croûte pas l'école
il lui a fallu prouver ses tirs trouver
des arguments les mettre en lumière
autant d'étapes qui ont permis de
convaincre les autres et de chasser les
avis que je faisais de l'ombre
construire sa réflexion pour démontrer
la véracité de son propos permet en
premier lieu développer son argumentaire
quand on est certain d'avoir une idée
qui pourrait révolutionner le monde on
ne se précipite pas à l'apport pour le
crier sur tous les toits on risquerait
de se casser les dents
il vaut mieux prendre son temps poser
des bases solides puis se lancer et
tenter de convaincre les potentiels
adhérents
pour rester dans le thème Steve Jobs
ancien directeur d'une célèbre compagnie
et inventeur américain est arrivé dans
les années 70 avec son produit et sa
volonté de casser les codes de
l'informatique sans mauvais jeu de mots
en plus d'avoir complètement changé nos
modes de communication monsieur James a
démontré à de nombreuses reprises ces
talents d'orateurs et sa manière de
conduire l'opinion
personne avant lui n'avait placé autant
d'efforts dans le marketing d'un produit
il savait qu'il se plaçait sur un
terrain ou rien n'était fait où il
fallait justement instaurer des normes
et il a su en profiter
car oui casser les codes parfois c'est
aussi les inventer
alors dit comme ça ça paraît un peu
paradoxal je vous l'accorde mais après
tout en code qu'est-ce que c'est et à
quoi ça sert pourquoi un master des
cotes si c'est pour que tout le monde
s'amuse à leur mettre en question voir
les détruire
en fait c'est un peu comme dans une
famille quand on cohabite avec nos
parents passer un certain âge il vaut
mieux en sauver certaines limites sinon
on finirait pas se lancer des objets
dessus
par exemple si Manu le petit dernier
s'occupe de faire la vaisselle le jeudi
soir il est logique qu'Eric l'aîné s'en
occupe le vendredi
ces petites règles permettent la vie en
communauté et on sort une sorte
d'équilibre pendant qu'on a l'impression
que tout le monde est sous les mêmes
restrictions que nous on s'embête pas
trop à se dire que ces dernières sont
injustes on se contente de les suivre
autrement dit si le traitement nous
paraît être égal il n'y a pas vraiment
de risque de révolte la plupart des cas
ce sont les injustices qui ont conduit à
des soulèvements
si vous vous rendez compte que votre
grand frère ne fait rien pendant que
vous nettoyez les toilettes vous aurez
vite fait de vous en plein dans vos amis
ou le signaler à vos parents pour
réparer cet abus
il vient dans la vie de tous les jours
c'est un peu le même processus
vous êtes des citoyens les lots vous
empêche de faire telle ou telle chose
et si vous vous rendez compte que l'une
d'entre elles est absurde ou injuste
vous vous empressez de rédiger un poste
énervé sur les réseaux sociaux tandis
que les plus agacés ils ont même jusqu'à
descendre dans la rue pour scander leur
colère car oui comme le dit si bien
Patrick Bruel casser les cotes c'est
aussi se casser la voix parfois
et en même temps si c'est Cannes
n'existait pas ce serait l'anarchie
totale
Eric et Manu passerait leur temps à
discuter Wandre
participerait pas vraiment améliorer
leur situation globale
pire encore son code ce serait on aurait
pu aucun moyen de comparaison ni prendre
repère le code de la route par exemple
il serait difficile de s'en débarrasser
complètement ici c'est presque une
obligation la story une signalétique
normée pour éviter les accidents vous
pouvez pas se contenter de démarrer le
moteur de sa voiture et croiser les
doigts pour nous en voir aucune autre
sur le trajet enfin sauf si vous vous
trouvez sur le rond-point des
Champs-Élysées et encore
en fait même si on voulait il nous
serait difficile de vivre sans aucune
forme de code ce sont un peu les cordes
qui font tenir la cabane qui est notre
société
notre existence même est soumise à des
contraintes naturelles vous vous
souvenez la gravité sans elle on serait
tous certainement en train de voler
librement
et encore il existe très sûrement un
code de vol
mais alors devons-nous pour autant ne
plus tenter de casser les codes
et bien comme vous avez pu le voir la
réponse n'est pas évidente
parce que si j'affirme haut et fort que
je veux casser les codes j'aspire
forcément un bouleversement
quand on s'engage dans le processus de
destruction on ne s'attend pas à
simplement ébranler la structure on veut
la voir s'écrouler
alors oui il est possible qu'une fois
que le bâtiment soit démoli on se met à
en construire un autre certes différents
pourtant toujours au même endroit
mais vraiment le nœud du problème
si pour cela on utilisait des matériaux
plus respectueux de l'environnement et
qui participerait à leur durabilité
peu importe qu'on se trouve dans une
boucle en fait il faudrait surtout
veiller à ne pas ériger une copie de ce
qui a été réduit en poussière
de la même manière
il ne faudrait pas se reposer ce qu'on
entend sur les codes qui nous savons ne
fonctionnent plus vraiment par exemple
quand on voit que notre consommation
plastique n'est plus compatible avec
notre environnement on ne peut pas
continuer à agir comme nous le faisions
50 ans en arrière
certes il est facile ne se refuser à
tout changement pour baigner dans un
confort d'apparence mais n'oublions pas
que les augmentent et que pour éviter la
noyade nous serons certainement obligés
de changer les habitudes
je ne voudrais pas terminer par dire que
nous serons contraints par nos propres
contraintes mais plutôt que si ce n'est
pas nous qui entamons des procédures
pour casser ses codes ils finiront
peut-être par se casser tout seul dans
l'urgence
on pourrait même dire que il serait
temps de casser certains codes pour
limiter la casse en quelque sorte
casser les codes finalement c'est avant
tout une épreuve quelque chose de
souhaité et souhaitable un combat mené
pour le bien commun ou pour notre propre
satisfaction
ça doit être porteur et nous donner un
team conviction que c'est en vaut la
peine que c'est nécessaire à notre
bonheur
ça peut être choisir un métier porter
certains vêtements s'engager dans une
association ou même aimer quelqu'un bien
sûr
quand on commence à se questionner ou à
innover on peut s'attendre à ce que tout
le monde ne dort pas à nos idées
l'essence là il n'y aurait plus
d'évolution
on serait éternellement bloqué dans un
monde où les gens ne se poseraient plus
de questions et où les rues seraient
remplis de maisons semblables les unes
aux autres
une existence qui en définitive serait
bien fade
il nous faut continuer d'oser prendre
des risques et faire certains sacrifices
car ne dit-on pas après tout on ne fait
pas d'omelette sans casser des œufs
merci